welcome back to spectrum that's not
vegan actually this time it is oh well
in that case a big thanks to curiosity
stream for sponsoring this episode
here's spectrum vegans I refuse to eat
at a table where people are eating
animal products and my mind it's the
same thing as if like you're eating a
dog or a child in front of me I guess
it's just like in the definition
veganism is a way of living which sees
through food as far as practicable and
possible all forms of animal
exploitation and cruelty to animals for
any reason clothing food it's about
animals being ethical for them I didn't
become vegan with any sort of ethical
reasoning in mind I just was very sick
all the time and I just had an
inclination that if I stopped eating
animal by-products that I would feel
better and I did and all the ethical
reasons came as a result of me looking
at my health and seeing that change I
definitely have stayed vegan because of
ethical reasons but I became vegan for
my health I became vegan for health
reasons but I think the end goal of
veganism is Animal Liberation so I don't
I feel like that's more plant-based when
you're vegan for health or vegan for
something else because at the end of the
day we seek to use products that have no
animals in them at all the reason why I
went vegan was for the environment
climate change is real you could do more
good for the environment
by being vegan than giving up your car
which is insane I guess the ethics came
afterwards which is why I like I agree
with you guys I feel like where we both
think the same things but why I started
wasn't for ethics which is why I'm here
this one's tough because I've bought
like a chicken burrito for my brother he
would go get it anyway and that's maybe
not the best way to go about it maybe I
should deter him but the way I try to
promote my diet is just by being an
example and not by forcing it into
someone else because I just think that
if maybe like I had bought a vegan
burrito
he was just like be resentful of
veganism even more because he didn't get
what he wanted buying it or preparing
animal products or anything that's not
vegan for somebody is enabling them to
fund very oppression that I'm against
like for me I've taken the liberation
pledge so like I refuse to eat at a
table where people are eating animal
products and my mind it's the same thing
as if like you're eating a dog or a
child in front of me you're not gonna
want to like stay at that table and be
with that you're gonna want to like try
to change those people okay so if you're
gonna try to change people don't you
think it'd be beneficial to sit with
them because then you could expose them
to your point of view so actually every
single person that I've told the
liberation pledge about they've had no
problem changing their meals and going
to vegan restaurants with me if you care
about me as a person how did you not
change one meal my approach is like
leading by example right all of my
family knows you're not going to come to
my house and bring any animals in or
asked me to prepare it but I do a lot of
cooking so I think what has brought me a
lot of joy is like taking everything
that I know my family loves to eat and
veganizing it and I've seen like my mom
my dad and my brother who I never
thought would go vegan in a million
years go vegan and I do know that if I
would have had the approach of like
judging them or you know
coming to aggressive it would not have
been that with love or understanding at
all not forcing it on them it has
actually helped them come over to the
dark side
where do you draw the line then I guess
like you're bending your own morals
every once in a while it's the same
thing with like meatless Mondays like we
don't have like homophobic free
Tuesday's so like it's the same thing
for me it's like you slip up it's like
saying like oh yeah I just like totally
fine with certain amounts of
exploitation if I'm doing it say you're
traveling and it's genuinely hard to
find like vegan food you can't like
survive on like just like lettuce all
the time and in certain like cultures
like say like China like it's really
hard to find something without me I've
grown up in different countries and
surrounded by different cultures and we
live in a place where Deegan ism is
almost mainstream and it's super
accessible but there's developing
countries where that's just not the case
even though like beyond burgers Gardein
like those aren't accessible worldwide
we have fruits and vegetables everywhere
and like I don't want to just tell
everyone to only like there's faces
that's not necessarily always true
because I've been in these situations
where it's just not really a sustainable
option to feed yourself a 100% vegan is
it more of like a convenience thing or
is it more of a like it's really there's
literally nothing available there's not
a banana or an apple or a bean I spent
three months near the Arctic Circle in
Iceland and in Iceland their diet is
just it's such a cold climate it's all
like sheep fish you know it's really
very because they don't have any fruits
or vegetables out there whatsoever at
all the climate doesn't allow for that
unless you're building greenhouses which
you know is like how they're moving but
in remote villages where there's only 20
people you know you can forage flowers
to make tea and like little berries here
and there but that doesn't sustain
people for the kind of climate
they experience where I would come from
Orange County is just a really nice
place to be vegan people really
understand why people are vegan every
now and then you get the ro you look
like you need a hamburger but I mean
it's not that bad I became vegan in 2006
and I didn't know anybody else who
didn't eat meat or was vegan like I got
left out of like a lot of dinner plans
and stuff like that with family and
friends
they didn't want to pick somewhere that
I could also eat it they wanted to stay
with what they wanted to eat I don't
think that I feel bullied for being
vegan now but when I first became vegan
I definitely did I get people who try to
take like my blackness away they'll say
you're not black if you're vegan how can
you be black and vegan and it really
does mess with your head I'll get a lot
of social media bullying to the point
where sometimes it does affect my mental
health just because I try to be a good
person but just someone finds out you're
vegan and it's like the world hates you
and I think it's really easy to bully
people online
I think if you consciously consume
leather and buy it and wear it because
you want to and you're conscious of that
choice then it's not vegan but the way
our society is structured there's so
many accidental cases in which you could
be owning or wearing a vegan thing like
you ride a bike a lot of bike seats are
leather and it's hard to always know
exactly what you're purchasing to me
it's like just not fair to the animals
for us to like abuse our own ignorance
and actually take the time to research I
think people do have excuses especially
in like queer neighborhoods they're
working so much they don't have the time
to consciously go out and research about
veganism I think that's more of an issue
that comes when you have more income and
more choice and I just want to say yeah
by the way this is fake leather this is
fake leather I think it's really
important though that we like have a
very clear message of what veganism is
because when we start to make excuses
then people who aren't vegan and are
just learning about it they have a
confused message of what it is
so I want to say like I'm a better
person than other people in general but
me as an individual I am a better person
than I ever was before and I guarantee
that anyone who goes vegan will be a
better version of themselves
I think I'm a better person because I'm
vegan but I know vegans who are racist
in homophobic and to me they aren't good
people you know I think they make good
choices when it comes to what they
consume I think to be vegan
which is why I was in somewhat disagree
because I feel like if you're racist and
you're homophobic or you're an oppressor
I'd feel like that's very anti vegan
just in my personal opinion I feel like
vegan as an anti discrimination anti
oppression movement it's really hard to
be racist and be vegan I would not
consider you're vegan if you're
homophobic or racist or something like
that because we are animals how can you
be discriminating against humans in that
form so that's why I'm here as someone
who's truly vegan who is of those values
in my personal opinion I don't feel like
they're better but I feel like they are
good
well I mean I'm a vegan but there's so
much more past diet that I haven't even
considered definitely whether you are an
omnivore or vegan I think we can agree
that the way we eat is always evolving
which reminds me of an amazing show on
curiosity stream called food of the
future which is a part of their dream
the future series yeah it's narrated by
Sigourney Weaver and it examines things
like vegetable protein urban farming
connected supermarkets and so much more
those of you don't know curiosity stream
is an amazing subscription streaming
service and for three bucks a month or
twenty bucks a year you can get
unlimited access to all those titles and
a few good humans out there a special
offer go to curiosity stream comm slash
Jubilee promo code Jubilee and get 30
days for free I've watched it on their
website but you can also watch it on
Apple TV Roku Amazon fire Xbox and
really all of your favorite streaming
devices so check it out and thanks for
watching